puis on souligne aujourd'hui le 10e
anniversaire du séisme en haïti
évidemment il ya des commémorations qui
ont eu lieu dans ce pays mais on sent
que la colère est encore présente et il
est toujours bien palpable on va
retrouver un autre collègue se financent
droit qui est à port au prince ce film
vous êtes en haïti depuis quelques jours
maintenant aujourd'hui vous êtes allé à
ces cérémonies de commémoration comment
ça s'est passé
la première cérémonie ce matin s'est
déroulée sur un site au mémorial du 12
janvier 2010 et un site en plein désert
au nord de la capitale c'est un site
très chargé d'émotion parce que le
mémorial a été érigé sur le site de
fosses communes où ont été enterrés des
milliers de victimes du séisme
donc une cérémonie sobre on a vu le
président jovenet le moïse déposé une
gerbe suivi d'un certain rock humain ce
qui était marquant c'est de constater
qu'il y avait certainement au moins deux
fois plus de policiers que de
dignitaires et de médias le public
n'avait pas accès à cet événement mais
une trentaine certainement peut-être un
peu plus de manifestants se sont invités
à la cérémonie
ils criaient à jeunesse mains propres
c'est un groupe qui réclame la démission
du président de tout le gouvernement la
réforme en profondeur de ce système ils
ont dit vous ne respectez pas les trois
cent mille morts les trois cent mille
haïtiens qui sont morts dans ce séisme
parce que si vous voulez respectiez vous
auriez fait autre chose que de vous
mettre de l'argent dans les poches
depuis dix ans donc oui vous disiez une
colère encore très palpable bon les
anciens qui se sont tournés vers les
églises pour commémorer à cet
anniversaire il ya eu de nombreuses
messes qui ont été célébrés
les haïtiens pris leur mort depuis une
dizaine d'années et certainement de
façon plus intense à chaque année le 12
janvier c'était encore le cas ce matin
mais quand on leur parle ils nous disent
en gros on a fait le deuil de nos morts
ce qui nous fait mal aujourd'hui c'est
que nous vivons toujours dans la misère
et que notre quotidien est encore plus
difficile qu il y a dix ans et c'est de
ça dont ils veulent nous parler je vous
propose d'écouter deux paroissiennes sa
vie parce que dix ans plus tard on agit
on dirait que
c'est toujours ça le petit monde des
médias et de la roma passé oui moi je le
phare de la surface de la mer noire
il y aura d'autres cérémonies véronique
cet après midi à 16 heures 53 ou au
moment où la terre a tremblé il y a dix
ans mais très bien on s'en reparle d'ici
là merci beaucoup se fie au revoir je
vous en prie